PROFESSOR: I wanted to make a
few comments on the third
problem set, which was
a funny puzzle.
And it was intended to be
entertaining and get you
thinking about things
related to symmetry
in an amusing context.
And there were two problems.
The first problem had a platter
on which there were
arranged cherries with either
two or three berries to a
spray, and apples and pears.
And they were either black or
white, which didn't make then
particularly appetizing.
But in any case, there were
three platters and the fruits
marched around on the platter.
And the puzzle was, what
would be the fourth
platter in the sequence?
This didn't involve symmetry
in any sense of the word.
But yet, what was going on from
picture to picture was a
mapping of the motifs from
one location to another.
Not just rotation or translation
or anything nice
in the crystallographic, but
still they were being moved
from one location to another.
And just about everybody
got the right
answer just by deduction.
But the reason I liked that
problem, and the reason I gave
it to you, is that it introduced
another sort of
transformation.
One of the pairs of fruits not
only change locations, but
they switched from black to
white as you went from one
position to the other.
And that is another sort of
transformation we can introduce.
And this is something we could
call color symmetry.
And I would observe that this
is something that you are
already very familiar with in
patterns, in particular, in
the pattern that is represented
by a checkerboard
where you have black squares
and white squares.
This location here is a bona
fide four-fold axis, as is
this location here.
But there other locations, such
as the corners of the
black and white squares, where,
indeed, there is a 90
degree rotation that takes this
square and transforms it
into this square.
But in doing that
transformation, you change it
from a black one to a white one,
and then from a white one
to a black one again,
back to a white one.
And that is a color symmetry.
You could make it red and green
if you like to be a
little more attractive.
Similarly, there are mirror
lines like this that are true
mirror lines.
The pattern is left invariant.
There's another locus such as
this one here where when you
reflect you go from a black one
to white one and then back
to a black one when you do
the operation twice.
So there are black-white mirror
planes as well as
regular mirror planes.
There are two-fold axes but all
of the two-fold axes are
black-white axes, white to
black, black back to white.
So that's a new sort of
transformation that we can
develop if we wanted to,
switching the color.
Does this is have any utility
in the physical sciences?
Be nice for wallpaper designers,
but does it have
utility in physical sciences?
And the answer is yes.
Because what is going on here
is that there is a binary
character assigned to
each of the motifs.
So any time the atom or
whatever you have, the
molecule, has some sort of
binary characteristic that it
can exist in two distinct
states, the arrangement of
that sort of motif requires
a black-white symmetry.
And one example in crystals
that requires this sort of
symmetry is the case of
a magnetic structure--
and I think I mentioned this
last time-- where the magnetic
moment can either point
up or down.
Well, saying that you have an
atom with spin up and an atom
with spin down is the same thing
as saying, in terms of
transformations, having a black
atom or a white atom.
It's a binary character that
switches from atom to atom.
Could you have three
color symmetries?
Yeah.
You can.
There is a Dutch artist named
Maurits Escher who spent much
of his, career deducing
patterns, and did this in a
purely intuitive way.
I mean you look at these
patterns and say, wow, that
guy is some crystallographer.
But I heard him, while he was
still alive, speak twice.
And he describes it in
metaphysical terms.
This is the twoness merging with
the fourness, and just
completely intuitive.
But his patterns are gorgeous.
And he has a number of very nice
ones that are three-color
symmetries.
And maybe later on in the
term, I'll bring in a
projector and show you examples
of some of these.
They're very entertaining.
All right.
So the purpose of that first
puzzle was to introduce you to
black-white symmetries.
Then the second puzzle on the
sheet was a pretty dumb thing.
There was a stack of blocks
and you said how many--
I asked how many blocks are
there in the stack?
And you could count them
up, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And If you did it right,
you came out with 32.
So that was pretty dumb.
Well, this was intended as an
example of how one can use
symmetry in the solution
of a physical problem.
Let's suppose that you were a
cowboy and you had to go out
and buy horseshoes for
a herd of horses.
Would you count the
number of feet?
No.
You'd count the number of horses
and multiply by four.
OK.
So there you'd be
using symmetry.
Now The point of this
problem really was--
You could have had this one.
We have just the exact
number seats.
The point of this problem was
that you have to, in assigning
a symmetry to a system,
usually make physical
assumptions.
When you do a derivation, as
we've been doing for the last
several days, we say this is a
four-fold access, and there's
no ambiguity whatsoever.
Because it's my ball game, and
I want it to be a four-fold
axis,
But when you're given a pattern
or given a crystal and
you have to assign a symmetry
to that crystal, you
invariably have to
make assumptions.
The person buying the
horseshoes, for example, has
to assume that five- and
six-legged horses are pretty
rare articles and that a horse
with only three or two legs is
going to be of little utility
to the rancher.
It Would probably have a limited
existence at the
ranchers expense.
So you're assuming that all
horse have four legs.
In looking at a crystal, though,
things are not that
easy to decide.
And let me give you a few really
practical examples.
A lot of mineral crystals grow
in fissures in the rock.
And let's suppose we've got a
crack, and bubbling through
this crack is a solution
that contains silica.
And as the solution cools
off, it will deposit
a crystal of quartz.
And this crystal of quartz would
probably grow looking
something like this.
And you would knock the crystal
out of the rock.
And you would say, what is the
symmetry of this crystal?
It doesn't appear to be anything
hexagonal about it.
But what's happened is this
crystal if it had developed in
a uniform environment would have
had a hexagonal shape.
But because the nutrients are
flowing in from one direction,
it tends to elongate
in that direction.
So how could you assign the
symmetry to that crystal that
you dug out of the rock?
Unfortunately, crystals do not
come with a legend on the
bottom that says quartz SIO2
space group P3 subscript 121,
made in USA.
You have to yourself assign
the symmetry.
And what you would do is you
would look at this face and
this face and you say, gee,
these angles, when I measure
them, all turn out to
be 120 degrees.
This face has a luster on
it that looks like the
luster on this face.
This face has little edge pits
on it, and they point in the
same way as the edge
pits on this face.
I can measure the electrical
conductivity and find that it
varies in a fashion consistent
with a hexagonal crystal.
And you would do any physical
test that you decided you
would need to make.
And then when you were all done,
you would say everything
that I can measure about this
crystal other than it's shape
is invariant to a 120
degree rotation.
Quartz has a hexagonal shape
very often, but actually only
this face, this face, and this
face are symmetrically
equivalent.
And there's only a three-fold
axis in there.
And if you look very carefully
at this crystal, you could see
some difference there, too.
The neighboring faces very often
have striations, very
faint striations on one face,
no striations on the
neighboring face.
So you find out all that can.
You have to make some
assumptions, and then on that
basis decide the symmetry.
Let me give you another
example.
This is a real one.
And one of the things that
it's fun to do is to grow
crystals from solution.
The Science Museum has little
kits that you can buy that
have some powder that you could
heat up in water and
then put it in a beaker and put
a string in there, maybe
with a little crumb of the
stuff that you dissolved.
And one of the crystals
that is nice for
this purpose is alum.
It's a cubic crystal.
And if you let the stuff set
there, it will form a nice,
lovely equiaxed cubed.
Science Museum usually puts a
pinch of another salt in there
so the crystal is not only
pretty and shiny, it's purple
or it's the orange.
Now, unless you attach this
little seed crystal carefully,
there would be a good chance
that it would fall off and
land on the bottom
of the beaker.
When that happened, your crystal
would not have the
shape of a cube.
It would have a shape in which
these two top edges had length
L and these faces on the side
were exactly half that length.
And what's happening is that
this crystal is growing in an
unconstrained environment.
The nutrient is coming on and
crystallizing from all
directions.
In this case, nutrient can't
get in from the directions
that are below the crystal.
So the growth in that direction
is eliminated, and
this height is exactly
half that at
the edge of the crystal.
So that's sort of a very
specialized case of a crystal
growing in a constrained
environment.
I'm digressing now, but let me
make a few more remarks.
The shape that a crystal has--
and the shape is in
crystallography designated by
a special term.
It's called habit.
Crystals that undergo plastic
deformation never die, they
just develop bad habits.
Oh, come on.
This is a tough crowd.
I thought that was
pretty funny.
Anyway.
The habit that a crystal has
can depend very much on
impurities in the solution or
melt from which it grows.
And let me suppose I start with
a little crystal that
looks like this.
And there are two different
kinds of faces on there.
And let's suppose one of them
grows rapidly and one of them
grows slowly.
Which face do you think would
be the one that eventually
forms the boundaries to
the crystal volume?
The fast-growing face or
the slow-growing face?
AUDIENCE: Fast-growing face.
PROFESSOR: Fast, slow are
both possibilities.
Let's do a time lapse
experiment.
Let's suppose that this is
the fast-growing face.
And, after a certain amount of
time these faces would have
all advanced to this location.
And this is the slow-growing
face.
And after the same amount of
time, it will have advanced to
this location.
After the next time increment,
this one would
have grown up to here.
This would only have
grown that far.
And you could see the only thing
that's gonna be left is
the slow-growing face.
So it's sort of counter
intuitive.
The faces that survive to bound
the crystal as rational
planes are the slow-growing
faces, not the
rapidly growing faces.
This is of great use to the
people who want to control
crystal shape.
And this is very often in very
every day, ordinary contexts.
The people who grow table salt,
for example, want to
grow a crystal that has nice
pointy edges so when it comes
down on your tomato, it
doesn't bounce off.
It sticks to it.
So the shape of table
salt makes a
difference in how it behaves.
And the way you change the shape
is to find something
that will be absorbed
preferentially on one set of
faces that you would like to
have be the faces that appear
on the crystal.
And that will do the
job for you.
I'll close with just one final
example of this in real, every
day industry or technology.
I once had a phone call from a
company that made salt for
sprinkling on roads in the
winter time, particularly
around New England when the
roads tend to ice up.
And in an earlier era it, was
politically correct to use
sodium chloride.
But you wanted the sodium
chloride, if you could, to
have an acicular, a needle-like,
shape to improve
its flow properties so you
didn't waste a lot when you
shook it out of the
back of the truck.
And the material that they use
for that-- you think rock salt
in the environment is bad--
they used a cyanide compound to
modify the growth habit and
make it needle-like.
And they wanted to get away
from that before they were
really dragged into some sort
of trial by the EPA.
And did I know of something that
could change the shape of
the salt crystals for them?
And the answer to that
question was quite
straightforward.
No.
That was the end of
the conversation.
But it was an interesting
example of how surface
chemistry can change
crystal shape.
OK.
So all that long-winded
explanation was a
justification of the
meaning of those
two final two puzzles.
And the final thing I have to
say about them is that these
puzzles were lifted
from a puzzle book
published by MENSA.
Have any of you heard
of MENSA?
MENSA is an association of
self-declared geniuses.
So this was a puzzle
book for geniuses.
And you all did horribly well
on that third problem set.
Everybody at MIT is bright.
But you folks are not only
bright, you are geniuses
because you cracked
the MENSA puzzles.
OK.
Enough enjoyment and
fun and games.
Let's get serious, back down to
what we were doing earlier.
We had established in earlier
discussion that there are a
very limited number of ways in
which we can arrange a mirror
plane and a rotation
axis about one
fixed point in space.
And these, accordingly, are
called the point groups.
And in particular, they are
the two-dimensional
crystallographic point groups.
We had rotation axes by
themselves, 1, 2, 3, 4, and 6.
And these are the only ones we
need worry about because these
are the only rotational
symmetries that are compatible
with translation.
Then we had a mirror plane.
And then there was no reason
why we could not combine a
mirror plane with these
rotational symmetries.
And in doing so, we used a
theorem that said if you take
two reflection operations,
sigma 1 and sigma 2-- and
again, I use sigma to represent
an individual
operation of reflection--
and a mirror plane is the
locus of operations of
reflection, and then reflecting
back again, there
are two operations involved.
And if these are combined at
some angle mu, sigma 1
followed by sigma 2, when they
are separated by an angle mu
is the same as the net
transformation of a rotation
about their point of
intersection through twice the
angle which the mirror
planes are combined.
And that led us--
in addition to a one-fold axis,
a two-fold access, a
three-fold axis, a four-fold
axis, and a six-fold axis--
let us combine reflection with
these axes to get symmetry
combinations that we named
according to the symmetry
elements which were present
in the final combination.
We used two mirror planes if the
mirror planes that arose
where independent.
Independent in the sense that
the two-fold axis never turned
one into another.
And independent in the sense
that if we draw a
representative motif, the way
those motifs were disposed
about one mirror plane was
different from the way they
were arranged about
the other one.
For a four-fold axis, we could
add mirror planes.
And they would have to be
at half the angle of the
four-fold axis.
And as we saw, it was
kind of a mouthful
to call this 4MMMMMMMM.
There were just two kinds of
mirror planes, so this one was
called 4MM.
6MM, analogously, was a six-fold
axis with mirror
planes separated by 30 degrees,
half the throw of the
six-fold axis.
And the one that I left out is
3, not m m but 3M because a
three-fold axis has
mirror planes
separated by 60 degrees.
And the same thing goes on at
each of these mirror planes,
pair of objects hanging at one
end of the mirror plane, the
other end is unadorned.
So they all behave the same.
There's only one kind
of mirror plane.
The three-fold axis maps one
mirror plane into another, and
so they have to be the same.
So therefore, only one M
appears in the symbol.
Independent of this, we had,
when we combined reflection or
rotation with a lattice, found
that there were a very limited
number of lattices in two
dimensions, the oblique
lattice which had T1 not equal
to T2 and T1 inclined to T2 by
some general angle.
The next degree of
specialization was for a
two-fold axis-- so either a
one-fold or a two-fold axis
could fit in here.
For a three-fold axis or a
six-fold axis, we had to have
a lattice in which the two
translations were identical to
one another, identical in
magnitude and identical in the
way the atoms were ranged
relative to these
translations.
And the angle between
T1 over T2 had to be
identically 120 degrees.
And by convention, we take the
larger of two angles, 120
rather than 60, to define
the inter axial angle.
A four-fold axis required a net
that was exactly square,
not approximately square
but exactly square.
So T1 and T2 had to be identical
in magnitude.
The angle between them had
to be exactly 90 degrees.
And close is no cigar.
It has to be exactly 90 degrees
because that angle is
generated by symmetry.
And then at the place in which
I'm gonna pick up today in
just a moment is the case of a
mirror plane and reflection,
we saw depending on how we
arranged the translations
relative to the reflection
plane, could give us either a
lattice in the shape
of a rectangle--
and here T1 and T2 made an angle
of exactly 90 degrees.
But the magnitude of T1 could be
anything it liked relative
to the magnitude of T2, and then
a double cell, which had
the shape of a diamond.
But it was operationally much
to our advantage to pick a
double cell which had
a right angle in it.
And the reason for that was that
it is a nightmare to do
calculations of inter-atomic
distances and angles or angles
between faces in an
oblique system.
The right angle makes these
calculations very simple.
And the fact that this cell
tells you twice as much of the
area as you really need
to know about is a
small price to pay.
So this is the rectangular
net, as
we'll call it in words.
And this is one that
we'll call the
centered rectangular net.
OK.
So let me pause here and suck
in air and see if there are
any questions.
This is where we left off.
And now having everything spread
out on the board, we're
going to start to make
combinations and
continue that process.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So the centered
rectangular has the same exact
[? intercept ?] as the
rectangular but the only thing
you're doing is you're deriving
it based on symmetry
that you're using like a diamond
kind of thing to get
the center one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So all these arose when we did
it slowly and systematically.
We said let's let this be the
location of the mirror plane.
What happens if we combine
it with a translation?
We can take one lattice point
on the mirror plane since
there's no unique
lattice point.
And then the mirror plane
is gonna reflect
this over to here.
So here's a first translation.
I've got a second non-colinear
translation.
Wham-o.
Instant lattice.
So what I'm doing is taking this
diamond shape and I am
taking one translation here--
let's put some labels on this.
Let's call this T1
and this T2.
So this translation here, call
it T1 prime, is my original
translation T1 plus T2.
In this translation, T2 is
the negative of the--
Yeah.
It's gonna be minus
T1 plus T2.
So I've taken linear
combinations of the two
vectors of the diamond-shaped
cell.
And again, this is contrary to
the rules we have that say
pick the shortest two
translations.
Why?
The final larger area of
volume then you need.
And the answer to that is
occasionally the provision of
a coordinate system, which is
far easier to work in, is a
small price to pay for
that redundancy.
OK.
And then the primitive
rectangular net, just to
remind you again, we said is
there any case in which this
is not true?
And that case was if you take
T1 exactly perpendicular to
the mirror plane and then you
define only a lattice row.
So that gives you a second
choice for T2.
You can't pick it anywhere you
like, otherwise it gets
reflected across just as in the
first case, and you have
two translations that
are not compatible.
And the only way that they are
compatible is that if you make
the translation T1 straddle
the mirror plane.
And that's what we've
already got up here.
So that's how we got the
rectangular net.
We could get a second distinct
sort of lattice only if this
translation was exactly in the
plane of the mirror line.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: But the number and
kind of symmetry elements are
the same for both, right?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Uh, so--
PROFESSOR: So there's a curious
sort of duality here.
Here in the case of a hexagonal
net, this is just a
lattice of a very specialized
shape.
And does that have a six-fold
axis in it?
No, not unless I decide
to put one in.
I could put in a three-fold
axis, alternatively.
So here, I have one lattice that
can accept two different
kinds of symmetry.
Here I've got the reverse
situation.
I have two distinct kind of
lattices, both of which are
happy and content with the
same symmetry on them.
So there's going to be a far
greater number of combinations
of lattice with symmetry than
simply a one-to-one
correspondence between lattice
types and point group types.
OK.
Any other questions?
All right so let me now shift
down to low gear and remind
you of one thing that
we did last time.
We asked what happens if I can
combine a rotation operation,
a alpha, with a translation?
Call this T1.
Sounds like something I already
did in showing that
the values of alpha are
restricted to values.
But what I'm going to do now is
use something that looks as
though it's a similar starting
point to arrive at a different
result that we saw last time.
I'm going to deliberately look
at a line that is alpha over 2
on one side of the perpendicular
to T1.
And then the operation of the a
alpha is going to take this
translation with a lattice point
of necessity at the end
of it, and it's going to move it
over to here, alpha over 2,
on the other side of the
translation of the
perpendicular.
Then I'm going to pick this up
with the translation T1 and
move it and everything along
it to a location like this.
And my question now is, what
is a alpha followed by the
translation T1?
The handedness of the objects
have not changed.
So this has to be either
translation or another rotation.
And what we can very quickly
show is if upon dropping a
perpendicular down to the
original translation, these
lines are parallel.
This line cuts across it.
So this angle is alpha over 2.
And this line is inclined
to the perpendicular
by alpha over 2.
So this angle in here is
also alpha over 2.
So the answer is that if I
rotate from one location to
another by rotation alpha and
then pick up that motif or the
entire space and translate it by
the original translation T1
to get a third one-- this is
number 1, right-handed, say,
number 2, right-handed.
This is number 3.
Stays right-handed.
Has to be related
by a rotation.
And we next ask, what point is
the point about which the
rotation occurs?
Then we used--
what at the time seemed like
a trivial observation--
that a rotation axis in space
or a rotation point in two
dimensions is the locus
that is left
unmoved by the rotation.
So if rotating from here and
translating over to here is
equivalent to a rotation and if
the locus of the rotation
has to be the point that's
left on moved, bingo.
That's where the rotation
occurs.
And it's through the same angle,
so we can label this an
operation b alpha.
And we know exactly where
that point is gonna be.
It's gonna be along the
perpendicular bisector of the
original translation.
And it's gonna be up a distance
x which is T over 2
times the cotangent
of alpha over 2.
So now we've got another, what
I call, combination theorems.
And again, this is nothing
more than knowing how to
complete the product of two
operations in establishing the
group multiplication table.
so let me write it down in the
form of a combination theorem.
This says that a alpha followed
by a translation is
another rotation--
in the same sense, both counter
clockwise in this example--
another rotation b alpha in the
same sense about a point
that is always T over 2 times
the cotangent of alpha over 2
along the perpendicular
bisector.
So that's how you would go about
making an entry in the
group multiplication table.
Sorry.
I put you off.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can you just, like, I just
want to see what you did
actually to the motif
in that drawing.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Rather than taking an
abstraction, an arbitrary line
that is at alpha over 2, I put
a motif in the space that
doesn't necessarily hang on this
particular locus that I
drew for reference.
And the rotation through alpha
would move it to here.
It's lagging behind
this first line.
It lagged behind the second
one by the same amount.
Then I pick it up and I move it
by the same translation and
that slides it over here, still
canted over to the left.
And now what I claim is that I
get from the first one to the
third one--
and actually should have
raised your hand on a
different matter.
This is out in front
of the translation.
So number 3 should sit here,
also to the right to the
translation.
And the way I get from 1
to 3 in one shot is by
rotating alpha b.
OK.
Now, a cautionary note just so
you do not use your new power
recklessly.
Let me emphasize that this is
an escalation in operations,
not in symmetry elements.
And the reason for that is
that a rotation axis, in
general, contains a number
of different rotations.
An n-fold axis has n different
rotation operations implied in
it, including the identity
operation of
rotating 360 degrees.
So if I say I'm gonna drop a
four-fold access in a lattice,
what I'm doing is dropping into
the lattice a 90 degree
rotation, a 180 degree
rotation, and
a 270 degree rotation.
And the location of the new
operations depends on alpha.
So these new operations
are not gonna pop
up at the same location.
They're gonna be sprinkled
over different locations.
So as an abstraction, that may
be hard to appreciate.
But we're going to straight
away derive a
couple of more additions.
And then when we see what
happens upon adding a rotation
axis to a lattice in a couple of
nontrivial cases, I'll just
summarize the results and assume
that you'll be able to
derive them on your own.
The last time we had got around
to doing just one of
these combinations.
And we ask what happens when you
combine with a translation
a rotation operation a pi.
So we'll take some motif that
sets up here, right-handed,
rotate it by 180 degrees to
get a second one, and then
pick that up and translate it by
T. So I'll get a third one
sitting down like this of
the same handedness.
And the question now is
how do I get from
1 to number 3 directly?
Well, let's use our theorem.
Our theorem says we should
go a distance x along the
perpendicular bisector, which
is half the magnitude of T
times the cotangent
of pi over 2.
The cotangent of pi
over 2 is zero.
So we go up a distance x.
That's equal to 0, all in the
perpendicular bisector, which
means we stay put.
And--
in this class, there is always
truth in advertising.
Around this locus here is a
rotation operation b pi, which
takes the first one into
the third one.
OK.
And now, lickety split, I will
derive again-- and I apologize
for going fast because I
did do it last time.
Let's ask what happens when we
combine a two-fold axis with a
parallelogram net?
So we're taking a two-fold axis
plus a parallelogram net.
In this two dimensional
lattice there are two
translations, T1 and T2, of
arbitrary magnitude with some
angle between them
that's arbitrary.
And to this lattice point,
I'll add a two-fold axis.
A two-fold axis involves the
presence of two operations,
the identity operation, and that
we can forget about, and
then there's the
operation a pi.
By combine a pi with T1, I'll
get an operation b pi that
sits at the midpoint of T1.
If I combine a pi with T2, we
get an operation c pi at the
midpoint of T2.
If I combine a pi with T1 plus
T2, I'll get another operation
d pi at the center
of the cell.
And we don't have to ask what
happens when we go three
translations over.
There's gonna be another
operation of 180 degree
rotation on that translation.
But we really only need bother
about what goes on on the
edges and in the interior of
one unit cell, because
whatever's there has to be
repeated by translation.
So, in making these additions,
we need consider only
independent translations--
that is, not related
to one another by
the rotational symmetry--
independent translations
that terminate
within the unit cell.
And that means for the addition
of a two-fold axis, I
need do only what I have,
in fact, just done.
I want to consider a pi with
T1, T2, and T1 plus T2.
If I have the operation a pi
or b pi or c pi or d pi at
these four locations, that is
all I need have present to say
that I have, in addition to the
two-fold axis that I added
to the lattice point, a two-fold
axis halfway along
T1, a two-fold access halfway
along T2, and another one
smack in the middle
of the cell.
These are lattice points.
So those axes have to be
repeated by translations, this
one from here to here, this one
from here, this one from
here to here.
So I'll have two-fold axes in
the middle of all of the edges
of the cell plus this fourth
one right in the middle.
So this is an example of a two
dimensional space group.
It's a symmetry that acts
on all of space.
And the names that we will give
to these combinations is
a symbol for the symmetry
element that we added, in this
case a two-fold axis.
And then we'll specify the
nature of the lattice to which
we've added it.
And all that I have to say is
that the lattice is primitive
because you're all aware at
this point that a two-fold
axis requires only
a primitive, a
parallelogram net.
The only place we'll need a
special symbol is when we add
a mirror plane to either the
rectangular net or the
centered rectangular net.
And then we'll have to specify
which type of lattice of that
shape, primitive or centered,
we're dealing with.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So all you did with
that derivation there is prove
that you don't have
to worry about any
rotations outside of that?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: That's correct?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Which is very fortunate 'cause
there's an infinite number
lurking outside the boundaries
of the cell.
I'll show you another
general truth.
What does a pattern look like?
The pattern looks exactly like
the pattern of a two-fold axis
with that pattern of motifs hung
at every lattice point.
These new two-fold axes don't
do any further repetition of
the motifs.
They don't do any repetition
of the motif.
They just express relation
between things that you get
when you take this pair and
then repeat it by the
translations.
So this two-fold access, for
example, relates this to this.
This two-fold axis relates this
one to this one, and this
one to this one, and so on.
They're just relations that
exist between the things that
you get when you add the pattern
of a two-fold axis to
a lattice point.
So another generalization of
what we're doing here that
turns out to be valid, the
pattern of motifs for a
particular plane group is
nothing more than the pattern
of the symmetry element--
symmetry element or symmetry
elements, sometimes we'll be
adding more than one--
that we've added to
a lattice point.
So in other words, if we take
2MM and drop that into a
rectangular lattice, the pattern
is simply gonna be
these four atoms related by 2MM
hung at every corner of
the lattice.
If you add it to a centered
lattice, these would be hung
at every corner of the lattice,
and also at the
centered lattice point.
So it's that simple.
If you look at some of these
high symmetry space groups or
plane groups, wow, there's
symmetry all over the place.
You say, how can I draw
a pattern for that?
Easy.
Just do what the point group
does and drop it in at the
lattice points.
So that turns out to be a
universal feature of all space
groups and plane groups.
OK.
Somebody had a question over
here and I cut you off.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
On that two [INAUDIBLE] diagram,
wouldn't you want to
use four of those because you
said it was-- you don't
concern ones that are-- you're
only concerned independent
ones, the ones you
can't get by--
PROFESSOR: You're absolutely
right.
And let's look at this
pattern again.
Here are a pair that are
hanging close to
this two-fold axis.
Here's a pair hanging close
to the two-fold axis, very
different arrangement, different
arrangement relative
to this two-fold axis, different
arrangements
relative to this
two-fold axis.
So what we're saying is-- and
this is the way, in fact, we
derive them--
that these four two-fold
axes are all distinct.
But the ones that are along the
edges are just related by
translation.
So why do I have
to put them in?
AUDIENCE: You just put them in
to just show the symmetry?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
Exactly. 'Cause if I say this
is a lattice and I have
two-fold axes here, that's an
incomplete representation
because if these are
translations, I jolly well
better have the same thing at
all the lattice points.
I'm just emphasizing the
property of a lattice which is
understood to be present in
all of these combinations.
OK.
Other questions?
And I would remind you that a
reasonable question or request
would be, could you
do that all again,
please, at half speed?
And I'd be happy to comply.
But really this is ground that
we covered last time.
And I'm just reinforcing it.
So now that we've run out
of time, we can go on to
something new.
Let me do, in the couple minutes
remaining, let me make
one more addition just to show
you how things change when you
add a rotation axis
that has more than
one rotation operation.
Let me ask what happens
when you add a
four-fold axis to a lattice.
We've seen that a four-fold
axis can coexist with no
lattice other than 1, which is
dimensionally square and which
has the same thing hanging
about, two translations that
are exactly 90 degrees apart.
So what we're doing is taking
a four-fold axis and drop it
in at the corner lattice point
and then step back before all
hell breaks looks.
Now, first thing we're gonna
do is to get the four-fold
axis at every corner
lattice point.
And then we're gonna use our
theorem, taking into account
that when I say I'm adding a
four-fold axis, I am adding
the operations a pi over
2, a pi, a3 pi over 2.
But let me call that, instead,
a minus pi over 2, the same
thing and a little easier
to deal with.
And then the operation a2 pi,
which is the same as the
identity operation.
And that's dull and
uninteresting, so we won't
consider that addition.
We've already done this,
a pi, in deriving P2.
And that's the nice thing
about this derivation.
It's gonna snowball because as
the symmetry gets higher,
we've already done the work for
the subgroup that contains
the elements that are present
in the higher symmetry.
So we'll get an operation
a pi over a pi here.
We'll get an operation
a pi here.
And if we take the diagonal
translation, T1 plus T2, I'll
get the operation a pi here.
Or I should probably call them
a pi, b pi, and c pi to
indicate that these are
different two-fold axes.
OK.
Let me emphasize again that this
theorem that we have is a
theorem in individual
operations and
not symmetry elements.
If I say a four-fold axis is
present, it means that all of
these operations exist
about that locus.
I cannot say that a four-fold
axis sits here.
I cannot say a four-fold
I'm gonna have to take each of
these combinations in turn and
then step back and see what
operations exist about the
various loci within the cell.
So the one that's really
different is the combination
of a translation T with the
operation a pi over 2.
And my theorem says if I put in
a motif and rotate it by 90
degrees to here--
so this is number 1 and
this is number 2--
and then translate it to a
location that's related to the
first by symmetry--
by translation to
get number 3--
they will be related by an
operation b pi over 2 that
sits up along the perpendicular
bisector by an
amount x, which is T over 2
times the cotangent of alpha
over 2, T over 2 times the
cotangent of 1/2 of pi over 2,
45 degrees.
The cotangent of 45 degrees is
unity because the two edges of
the triangle are equal
in length.
So this says I should go up
along the perpendicular
bisector by an amount that is
half the length of the cell.
And that puts me right in
the middle of the cell.
So the operation b pi over 2
sits not at the edge of the
cell, but at the center
of the cell.
And that, I think you will
agree, even in this hastily
sketched diagram, is the way
number 1 is related directly
to number 3 in one shot.
Now I could do it on the
cheap from here.
But let's show that
we have first an
operation a pi over 2.
We've already got the
operation c pi.
Let's now combine the operation
a minus pi over 2.
And that says that for c minus
pi over 2, I would go up the
perpendicular bisector a
distance T over 2 times the
cotangent of minus
1/2 of pi over 2.
And the cotangent of a negative
angle is minus that.
So I go a distance minus
T over 2 along the
perpendicular bisector.
And what that is gonna do is to
bring me to the center of
the cell that's directly
below.
And this will be the rotation
c minus pi over 2.
But everything has to be
translation equivalent at the
interval T. So I can just move
this operation c minus pi over
2 up to the center of
my original cell.
So now I have at the center of
the cell all the operations of
a four-fold axis.
So a four-fold axis exists in
the middle of the cell.
And let me write the
results in here.
I've now got all of the
operations of a four-fold axis
sitting here.
I've got all the operations
of a two-fold axis
sitting here and here.
So this is the final result,
if I translate the two-fold
axes over to the other
edges of the cell.
AUDIENCE: What is that angle
[? by the d project? ?]
That should be 90 degrees?
PROFESSOR: That should
be 90 degrees,
if I drew it carefully.
Yeah.
So let me give the final result
with a pattern in it.
These are the two translations,
equal in length,
four-fold here, four-fold
here, four-fold here.
They are all the same
four-fold axis.
Four-fold axis in the
middle of the cell.
Two-fold axis in the middle
of the cell edges.
And the pattern of objects is
the set of things that are
rotated by 90 degrees that form
a square about the corner
of the cell.
Another one here.
Another one that sits up here.
And another one that
sits like this.
Four of them on the corners
of the square.
And that's all we're going
to get in this pattern.
Again, it's just a pattern of a
four-fold axis that is hung
at every lattice point
of the square net.
And these other symmetry
elements that arise simply are
things that relate to the
squares that are hanging at
every corner of the
square cell.
OK.
So the square in the center of
the cell, for example, relates
these four.
And you can pick any other
four and they'd
be related as well.
The two-fold axis relates
this to this.
This two-fold axis relates this
to this and this to this.
So the pattern is just the
square produced by four
stamped out at every corner
of the square net.
And it's that simple.
The name of this thing--
what have we done?
We've taken a four-fold
axis, we've put it
in a primitive net.
I don't have to tell you it's
squared because in your heart
of hearts know that
that is what a
four-fold axis requires.
So this describes
completely the
combinations that's been made.
And this is a representative
pattern.
A pattern of this sort is one
that we've seen several times
already in describing
sample symmetries.
That is the plane group
of square floor tiles.
It's the plane group of the
square mesh that's in the
overhead lighting fixtures.
It's the pattern that is present
in the tiles up above
the lighting fixtures.
It's a pattern that is very
commonly present in square
shirts, but not too often.
It's kind of dull and
uninteresting.
Yes.
Fellow back there against the
wall wearing P4, probably
didn't know until now.
Thank you.
Actually, he's a shield.
I made him come in.
I called him up last night
and said be sure
you wear the P4 shirt.
And he said, OK, I will.
All right.
I'm getting silly.
So that's tells me it's
time to quit.
So let's take our usual
10 minute break,
And then we'll resume.
And I think I'll go lickety
split through the remaining
plane groups that consists of
combinations of a rotation
with a lattice.
OK.
So do come back.